en parler on reçoit tout de suite régis
le sommier grand reporter rt france
bonsoir régis merci d'être avec nous on
vient dans notre correspondante parler
de deux lignes rouges clairement est-ce
que la russie et l'otan envie d'elle et
cette fois-ci jusqu'à la la
confrontation est ce que ça peut
clairement bardet ces prochains temps
alors ce qui est certain c'est que la
question ukrainienne est pas résolue
elle est toujours en ou en jachère
depuis depuis 2016 et que c'est toujours
un point de crispation néanmoins quand
on entend parfois s'exprimer en occident
aux états unis entendent dire oui il y à
des manoeuvres militaires au sein de la
russie on n'entend pas quand il y à des
manoeuvres militaires au sein des états
unis des gens c'est comment dire
s'étouffer en se disant tiens il ya des
manoeuvres militaires sur leur propre
sol alors ces manoeuvres militaires
elles sont réelles elles existent et
elles existent en plus avec un certain
nombre de chars qui ont été déployés ce
conseil il ya un article très
intéressant justement du wall street
journal aujourd'hui qui explique que les
ukrainiens ont reçu de l'armement
américain ils ont reçu d'armements
américains notamment des missiles anti
char qui s'appelle des missiles javelin
et ses missiles ont une particularité
d'être assez redoutable justement contre
cette arme blindés ils ont reçu
également des drones turcs dont on sait
qu'ils ont été utilisées au karabagh
palais par les azerbaïdjanais avec un
succès assez dévastateur contre larmes
brin blindés arménienne donc c'est
démodé des commandes des nouveaux
armements dont disposent les ukrainiens
et ce qu'on a ce qui a été remarqué
justement c'est qu' un certain nombre de
chars russes ont reçu des équipements
pour parer justement à ces nouveaux donc
il ya vraiment
préoccupante ça veut dire quel point la
situation est une situation où oui de
part et d'autre on montre ses muscles je
pense qu'il se produit une chose parce
qu'il faut concevoir que aujourd'hui
donc on
donc manoeuvre comment personnel
militaire armes comme en char du côté
russe mais ce qu'on oublie de dire aussi
c'est que du côté de l'otan il y a aussi
dans les pays limitrophes d une présence
d'armement une présence d'armé par
exemple moi je j'ai été surpris de
constater en avril dernier quand je me
trouvais au sahel j'ai discuté avec des
commandes effort spécial estonienne qui
sont déployés qui est de la france au
sahel j'aurais demandé pourquoi
l'estonie alors avis comment intervenez
nous aider dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme je m'attendais à voir une
réponse comme je m'attendais à ce qu'on
me dise oui c'est pour éviter qu'ils les
terroristes en europe pas du tout les
estoniens m'ont dit parce que la france
est présent dans notre pays et qu'elles
nous aident à comment à garder notre
indépendance sous-entendu la france et
tourner évidemment vers la russie donc
ces manoeuvres là elle existe dans les
deux sens on a un peu tendance à penser
que elles ne sont que que dd comment que
du fait des russes ensuite il faut
comprendre la situation dans laquelle
des états unis se trouvent aujourd'hui
avec le retrait d'afghanistan avec le
retrait programmé pour la fin de l'année
de l'irak on sait qu'ils vont conserver
environ 2500 hommes en irak mais qu'une
grosse partie de ce qu'ils avaient va
être retirée d'irak donc les etats-unis
sont dans une position de repli et de re
déploiement dans d'autres zones
notamment la zone indo pacifique qui
concentrent aujourd'hui toute leur
attention on a dans le même temps il
faut rappeler les etats-unis ont dit
qu'ils allaient renforcer leur présence
militaire sur l'île de guam et renforcer
également leurs bases en australie les
chinois ont réagi immédiatement en
disant il faut arrêter cette mentalité
de guerre froide que les états unis à
nouveau réactive par rapport au
programme à l'entreprise décrétée par
donald trump aussi de repli des soldats
américains souvenez-vous d'allemagne de
les faire descendre au nom de 2500 et
bien joe biden a décidé d'aller contre
cette décision de son prédécesseur et de
conserver en allemagne un certain nombre
de troupes donc il ya une forme je
dirais de redéploiement des états unis
qui a été le manifeste quand avec le
retrait de leur retrait d'afghanistan
est aujourd'hui une peut-être parce que
je ne pense pas qu actuellement ce soit
réellement la menace russe qui soit
l'objectif numéro 1 des états unis mais
c'est plutôt d'arriver à contrer
l'expansion ce qu'ils jugent comme étant
hautement problématique c'est à dire
l'expansion de la chine et notamment
l'augmentation de son potentiel
militaire alors cette réunion à régis de
l'otan un soutien évidemment on s'est un
moment d'instabilité sur le flanc
oriental de l'otan vous l'avez décrit et
les alliés doivent ayant aussi se
pencher sur la crise migratoire la
frontière pologne biélorussie alors ça
c'est une ce qu'on a constaté c'est
finalement comment alexandre loukachenko
a très bien appris d'un autre comme en
autocrate célèbre récep t elle erdogan
qui déjà avait brandi le comment le
chiffon migratoire en accompagnant
souvenez-vous des migrants à la
frontière avec la grèce la grèce avait
réagi à l'époque en mettant son armée
devant les barbelés exactement de la
même façon que la pologne a réagi en
mettant son armée et sa police devant
s'émeut devant des barbelés le la crise
migratoire n'est plus simplement un
drame humanitaire elle est plus
simplement un comment une drame de la
pauvreté et de la guerre elle est
devenue une arme ce qu'a dit anthony
blinken est tout à fait exact une arme
politique aujourd'hui est évidemment
comment les 109 kenshin qu à utiliser
cette arme ensuite à faire comment
manier le chaud et le froid en faisant
revenir chez eux une partie des migrants
qui s'étaient déplacés qui a une
autorisation d'ailleurs de prendre les
avions pour se rendre en biélorussie
donc aujourd'hui ça c'est une bonne
supplémentaires qui aggrave les tensions
qui complique finalement les relations
entre l'otan et la russie et on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui oui le seul
qui peut dire à loukachenko de se calmer
et de comment d'arrêter de menaces de
brandir cette menace évidemment c'est la
limite poutine merci beaucoup régis le
sommier d'avoir été avec nous avoir
porté notre éclairage ce soir